18 minutes pour changer le monde c'était
le principe fondateur des têtes talk
lorsque richard goodman dans les années
80 4 a lancé
c'est ce nouveau concept en préparant ce
taux que je me suis demandé si les
technologies de l'information pouvait
participer à ces changements
s'il y avait des moments dans l'histoire
passée notamment au siècle dernier où on
avait expérimenté ces changements
disruptive violent brutaux avec un
impact sur nos sur nos vies et plus
particulièrement si l'informatique
cognitive allait permettre de nouveaux
types de changements et c'est ce que
nous voyons apparaître en ce moment
alors si on retourne en arrière au tout
début de ce que l'on appelle
informatique l'informatique d'ailleurs
un terme qui est apparu dans les années
60 4 ils avaient des systèmes issus des
tabulatrices dès les tous premiers
systèmes automatisés qui avait quitté
les fils des machines à écrire des
calculatrices des systèmes de pointage
ces systèmes avait la représentation du
programme et le tableau de bord
électriques que vous pouvez voir ici les
datas les données étaient transférés
sous forme de cartes perforées et tout
cela servait à construire les tout
premiers systèmes de comptabilité des
analyses statistiques de recensement les
tout premiers systèmes informatiques
donc au tout début de notre siècle
dernier
ensuite il ya une première grosse
évolution avec l'apparition des avec
l'apparition des langages les langages
de programmation il ya une quantité de
langage de programmation qui sont
disponibles actuellement il y en a de
nouveau qui apparaissent très très
régulièrement et si on se penche sur les
langages qui ont été importants au
siècle au siècle précédent
on peut citer le cobol par exemple au
début des années des années 60 qui a été
un langage utilisé pour écrire les
premiers systèmes de gestion de l'armée
américaine quelques années après le
basique qui lui est né au sein de
l'université et qui a été
destiné à permettre à deux noms
scientifiques d'écrire des applications
un peu plus tard dans les années 80 le
visual c++ pardon le java quelques
années après qui eux ont utilisé les
approches de l'orientation objets pour
garantir la portabilité des solutions
développées sur plusieurs types de
systèmes d'exploitation jusqu'au tout
dernier langage qui sont nés pour
permettre de programmer tous les jolis
outils mobiles que vous avez tous dans
vos mains en ce moment les langages y en
a beaucoup ils ont encore une très belle
une très belle vie devant eux et nous
arrivons avec les années 2000 dans une
nouvelle un nouveau moment destructif
d'évolutions technologiques auxquels on
a donné le nom de cognitives et en fait
pour le résumer l'objectif est de faire
fonctionner les machines les ordinateurs
de la même façon que fonctionne l'esprit
l'esprit humain si on se positionne
comme étant observateurs de notre monde
dans un contexte où l'on veut prendre
une décision que faisons nous nous
observons le monde qui nous entoure nous
interprétons les informations que nous
avons autour de nous nous les évaluons
en fonction du contexte et finalement
nous prenons la décision que fait un
expert d'un expert fait tout simplement
la même chose il fait la même chose sauf
qu'il le fait dans un contexte où la
quantité d'informations qu'il est
capable d'évaluer la complexité de ces
informations les règles entre ces
informations sont à un niveau de
complexité qui va au delà de monsieur
tout le monde
le problème c'est que cette quantité
cette complexité d'information ne fait
qu'évoluer on dit même qu'elle ne fait
qu explosé et donc c'est là où le
système cognitif entre en jeu pour
permettre à l'expert de considérer des
quantités d'informations pratiquement
illimité il n'y a pas de limite à la à
la technologie de ce point de vue là
donc l'expert quel que soit son domaine
de compétence
aidé par le système cognitif il pourra
procéder de la même façon mais avec une
capacité
été augmenté et une prise de décision
qui sera encore plus encore plus
éclairés si l'on retourne un peu en
arrière
il est intéressant de regarder la façon
dont ibm a procédé pour mettre à
l'épreuve ces nouvelles technologies et
une première expérience a été fait en
1997 lorsqu'un computer a été construit
de façon volontaire pour affronter un
champion d'échecs dans ce contexte là
l'objectif était de faire du calcul
massif des calculs simples parce que
même si le nombre de co2 combinaison des
coûts des chèques les règles des échecs
sont extrêmement nombreux c'est quand
même un nombre fini les règles sont
connues on allait simplement tester de
la capacité de la puissance de la
puissance informatique au début des
années 2010 donc
ibm a sert proposé delà même de la même
façon avec la même approche en utilisant
un jeu grand public pour exposer les
principes du du cognitif et les mettre à
l'épreuve
watson a affronté les deux gagnants
historique du jeu jeopardy
un jeu américain qui ressemble beaucoup
à notre question pour un champion des
jeux et des led et des lettres
avec un peu plus de complexité les deux
gagnants et historique et en le gagnant
qui avait gagné une un nombre de
victoires le plus important est le
gagnant qui avait gagné à montant le
plus important ce jeu était
particulièrement adapté pour tester les
principes du cognitif ont testé la
compréhension du langage humain la
capacité à aller chercher des réponses
sur la base de cette compréhension de la
question qui avaient été posées en
langage naturel d'évaluer la valeur de
la réponse qu'ils étaient trouvés et
ensuite de buzz et le tout dans un temps
au maximum d'une seconde pour rester
compétitif par rapport à ses concurrents
à ses concurrents humains
alors watson a gagné mais watson n'a pas
gagné du premier coup il a appris il a
perdu beaucoup de fois il a dit beaucoup
de bêtises mais le concept grâce à ce
jeu le concept du cognitif était testée
il était en place et il a pu
il a pu évoluer donc un système cognitif
est un système qui n'est pas défini il
n'est pas programmée il n'est pas
définie par un an par un langage mais il
permet de d'interagir avec la machine
sous forme de questions réponses en
langage naturel
il permet d'émettre des hypothèses
d'évaluer la valeur de ces hypothèses le
corpus d'informations qui est utilisée
est un corpus d'informations en langage
non structurées ce que l'on appelle non
structurées c'est tous les textes qui
peuvent être issus des réseaux sociaux
qui peuvent être issues de rapports de
médecins qui peuvent être issus de deux
rapports technologies qui peuvent venir
de tout de toutes les sources et la
chose intéressante excès que l'on est
déjà au travail bien entendu pour
analyser deux autres sources
d'informations non structurées que sont
le son et l'image
c'est un travail en cours et dernier
aspect un système cognitif s'adapte et
apprend il s'adapte au contexte des
questions qui lui sont posées et il
apprend au fur et à mesure des
interactions qui sont mises en place
alors ils s'adaptent au contexte prenait
1 prenant un exemple si je dis apple
apple dans le monde de la cuisine dans
le monde
dans un contexte géographique ou dans un
contexte informatique comprenez bien que
le sens n'est pas du tout le même
voilà c'est l'adaptation au contexte
extrêmement importante pour pouvoir être
pertinent dans les réponses qui sont qui
sont fournis alors il y a beaucoup de
solutions qui sont actuellement en
développement qui sont présentes sur
différents marchés
elles ne sont pas toutes au même niveau
de maturité à toronto par exemple au
niveau de ce service de néonatalogie les
systèmes a été mis en place pour
anticiper l'aggravation de l'état de
santé des des nouveau nés les les
moniteurs remonte plus de 1000
informations par seconde sur avec les
données vitales de ces de ses enfants et
pouvoir anticiper le plus possible en
utilisant des modèles d'analysé
prédictive pouvoir anticiper
l'aggravation de certains enfin
l'interprétation de certains symptômes
qui prédisent l'aggravation d'état santé
des nourrissons peu tout simplement
permettre de le sauver de sauver des
vies il y a eu les expériences ont
montré que par exemple le le le
un battement cardiaque trop régulier
pour un bébé dans ces conditions-là
pouvait être un signe d'une infection
qui se mettait en place
et dans ce contexte là il ya eu des
anticipations qui ont pu être faits
jusqu'à 24 heures avant que les premiers
signes cliniques n'apparaissent est ce
qui a permis à la fin tout simplement de
sauver des vies vous restez avec moi on
passe dans un tout autre contexte les
des enquêtes ont été faites les citoyens
que nous sommes sont beaucoup plus
généreux dans leurs dons
si nous nous sentons informer sur
l'utilisation des dons que nous que nous
faisons c'est la constatation café cette
société qui s'appelle field abilities à
m6 une société américaine qui a créé des
systèmes qui permettent de s'informer
d'analyser la l'utilisation des dons qui
sont faits à des ong notamment prenons
cet exemple où je considère la
possibilité de faire un don auprès de
cette ong écologiques il travaille
particulièrement sur la sauvegarde des
fonds marins et je me connecte à watson
pour poser quelques questions sur sur
sur par exemple le réchauffement
climatique et l'impact qu'il peut avoir
sur les sur les fonds marins
watson me donne
un certain nombre de réponses ce qu'il
est important de préciser à ce niveau là
c'est que les réponses contrairement à
ce que font les moteurs de recherche
sont des réponses qui sont pertinentes
avec ma question c'est à dire que les
réponses qui me sont proposées ne
dépendent pas purement de mots clés ne
dépendent pas de fréquence de
consultation de ces informations là ne
dépendent pas de de liens commerciaux
mais son ont été analysés par rapport à
l'heure à leur contenu
je reste dans mon contexte j'habite en
france je peux poser plus de questions
particulièrement que fait df dans ce
monde là je continuer à interagir je
pose des questions jusqu'à avoir être en
capacité de prendre ma décision je fais
un don ou pas et elle effectué je vais
faire un saut encore dans un domaine
encore complètement différent la cuisine
chef watson chef hassan ce sont les
concepts du cognitif appliqué à la
cuisine chaque fois tu sonnes à ingérer
c'est le cas de le dire
la composition chimique moléculaire des
ingrédients à ingérer une quantité
d'infos de recettes disponibles a aussi
appris quels étaient les goûts quels
étaient les habitudes alimentaires en
fonction des origines des régions du
monde des cultures des religions et
toutes ces informations lui permettent
d'aider des chefs notamment une école de
cuisine à new york avec laquelle il y a
un partenariat d'aider des chefs à
dépasser leurs préjugés à dépasser leurs
notions acquises de d'ingrédients qui se
marient bien ensemble pour inventer des
recettes complètement complètement
nouvelle comme le but rite au chocolat
comme un kebab au curry au phrasé à la
pomme et d'autres d'autres choses encore
alors d'accord c'est bien la créativité
mais il ya beaucoup d'autres aspects qui
sont en train d'apparaître dans ce
domaine là un des aspects c'est la
gestion du du gaspillage qui peut être
facilité donc justement en utilisant les
gradins ingrédients qui sont disponibles
et un autre aspect encore la facilité de
prévoir des régimes qui soit adapté non
seulement aux goûts mais aussi à des
régimes obligatoires comme le diabète
il y au diabète ou liés à l'hypertension
d'autres d'autres choses encore alors un
cocktail à base de cidre et de l'art qui
est le très beau parent et il est
beaucoup plus sain que d'autres que
d'autres mélanges
je vous présente now et sa grande soeur
peppers des robots des robots et pepper
particulièrement et a été conçu pour
partager sa vie avec les humains elle
est capable de lire nos émotions de
comprendre nos émotions
sur la base des indications que nous lui
donnons par notre voix par nos mimiques
faciales par notre comportement et de
pouvoir par exemple nous passer notre
morceaux de musique préférés pour nous
remonter le moral si c'est ce qu'elle a
ce qu'elle a détecté alors oui watson
vous le dirai dans ce dans ce contexte
watson est en train d'apprendre et à à
parler et à penser japonais peppers et
créé par une société qui est la filiale
d'un gros groupe de télécoms au japon
donc peppers aura bientôt un cerveau qui
sera watson qui permettra de faire
différentes choses proposer des recettes
on vient de le voir mais aussi de
proposer de travailler avec des enfants
pour leur faire apprendre leurs tables
de multiplication ou plein d'autres
activités encore tous types d'activités
pour lesquels une réponse personnalisée
qui peut tirer un bénéfice de l'analyse
d'une grande masse d'informations est
vraiment très adaptée pour une approche
de type cognitive
j'ai plein d'autres exemples à partager
notamment ross l'avocat des voeux le
cancérologue le
l'assistant de call center le conseiller
bancaire pour l'élaboration d'un
portefeuille de d'investissement web les
heures la société le voyagiste auquel
vous pouvez vous adresser en disant j'ai
30 ans je veux aller en toscane cet été
j'ai un budget de 2000 euros un enfant
de deux ans proposez moi quelque chose
et vous recevrez une une réponse
pertinente mais fondamentalement ce que
je veux vous dire c'est que la
technologie existe les idées c'est vous
qui les avez
allez-y révolutionner